AND SENT SITTING UP TO 57
MONTHS.
IN AMERICA IN HAS A LECTURING
HEADQUARTERS TONIGHT, A NEW CALL
FOR SOCIAL JUSTICE FROM A
DEMOCRATIC FRESHMAN LAWMAKER IS
BEING SUPPORTED TONIGHT BY ONE
OF THE LEADING DEMOCRATIC
PRESIDENTIAL HOPEFULS.
CORRESPONDENT KRISTIN FISHER
TELLS US WHAT'S IN THE PROPOSAL
AND WHY IT IS TOP CANDIDATE >>
FIRST IT WAS MEDICARE FOR ALL,
THEN THE GREEN NEW DEAL, NOW
CONGRESSMAN
ALEXANDRIA OCASIO CORTEZ WHO IS
PUTTING HER WEIGHT BEHIND THE
NEW PLAN TO FIGHT POVERTY.
>> WE ARE CALLING IT --
>> THE PLAN CALLS FOR CAPPING
ANNUAL RENT INCREASES PRESSURING
FEDERAL CONTRACTORS TO OFFER
BETTER WAGES AND BENEFITS IN
OBTAINING THE NATIONAL POVERTY
GUIDELINES TO TAKE INTO ACCOUNT
ACCESS TO HEALTH INSURANCE, HOT
CHILD CARE, AND THE NEW
NECESSITIES LIKE INTERNET ACCESS
AND ALLOWING UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS TO HAVE FULL ACCESS T
IMMIGRANTS TO HAVE FULL ACCESS O
SOCIAL WELFARE PROGRAMS.
>> A JUST SOCIETY EMBRACES OUR
IMMIGRANTS.
>> 2020 CONTENDER
SENATOR WARREN'S WAS QUICK TO
ANNOUNCE HER SUPPORT OF THE PLAN
BY SAYING IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
BIG STRUCTURAL CHANGE TO TACKLE
POVERTY AND INEQUALITY IN THE
U.S. AND AOC'S ADJUST SOCIETY IS
JUST THE TYPE OF BOLD
COMPREHENSIVE THINKING WE WILL
NEED TO GET IT DONE.
AS WARREN SURGES IN THE POLLS,
SO DOES THE POSSIBILITY OF HER
PROPOSAL TO BREAK UP BIG TEX.
FACEBOOK CEO MIKE ZUCKERBERG WAS
CAUGHT ON TAPE TELLING EMPLOYEES
THAT HE WOULD LIKELY HAVE NO
CHOICE BUT TO SUE THE U.S.
GOVERNMENT IF WARREN WINS.
>> SHE WAS ELECTED PRESIDENT, I
WOULD EXPECT WE WILL HAVE A
LEGAL CHALLENGE AND WE WOULD WIN
THE LEGAL CHALLENGE.
>> WARREN RESPONDED BY SAYING
WHAT WOULD REALLY SUCK IS IF WE
DON'T GET THE CORRUPT SYSTEM
THAT LETS GIANT COMPANIES LIKE
FACEBOOK ENGAGE IN ILLEGAL
ANTICOMPETITIVE PRACTICES.
WARREN'S DRIVE COMES THAT SAINT
BERNIE SANDERS' EXPENSE AS THE
TWO SURGE FROM THE FAR LEFT.
MASSIVE FUND-RAISING NUMBERS
OVER THE LAST FEW MONTHS.
HIS CAMPAIGN RAKED IN MORE THAN
$45 MILLION SINCE JULY.
THE BIGGEST QUARTER YET FROM A
2020 DEMOCRAT.
MAYOR PETE BUTTIGIEG ALSO HAD AN
IMPRESSIVE THIRD-QUARTER HOLE
AFTER A SOME SPENT LANGUISHING
IN THE SINGLE DIGITS OF
MULTIPLES, HIS CAMPAIGN TOOK IN
ABOUT $19 MILLION FOR THE
QUARTER CEMENTING MAYOR PETE'S
PLACE WITHIN THE TOP TIER.
BUT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WINS THE
DAY.
IT JUST ANNOUNCED A PRESIDENTIAL
FUND-RAISING RECORD ALONG WITH
THE REPUBLICAN NATIONAL
COMMITTEE, IT RAISED
$125 MILLION OVER THE LAST THREE
MONTHS AND TO PUT THAT IN
PERSPECTIVE, FORMER